[Music]
[Sandra Occhipinti]
The NLM Herb Garden is uh is one of the
demonstration gardens that are maintained
by Montgomery County Master Gardeners.
We're here two to three hours, one day a week, to
maintain the garden, plant, mulch, weed, trim.
[Pat Kenny]
This was apart of the National Institutes of Health
celebration of the Bicentennial in 1976.
The Potomac Unit Herb Society of America was
asked to take over the care of the garden.
It was a blessing for me because I lived close by.
I was interested in herbal plants.
I was interested in good health.
[Occhipinti]
So Rosemary, we think of as a culinary herb.
Rosemary is said to improve
memory and concentration.
It was also used to cure headaches. And there
are a lot of culinary herbs in this garden.
And they were all used medicinally.
This is Valerian.
It was used for insomnia and as a sedative.
[Kenny]
But most of the culinaryherbs,
most of the herbs we use for
cooking, have antibacterial, antiviral,
anti-inflammatory, and all kinds of phytochemicals
constituents that nowadays we know are medicinal.
What I love about this garden is this
shows some of the history of medicine.
[Occhipinti]
One of the times thatI was in the garden,
and a young man, a patient
from the Clinical Center, came into the garden.
And he said "Excuse me, I walk here. I walk to
this garden every day and I just
wanted to thank you... for it."
And it was, I was a complete mess.
But it was still, you know, with a
garden and you've got textures and colors
and flowers and and it's always changing.
And it it was very important
therapeutically to him.
And it's certainly therapeutic to work in it.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]